[Music]
um I suggestions
people really want to go in there I'm
not sure but I think that there's
already been a whole generation that has
been indoctrinated with metaverse
those of us that are older it's hard to
live
[Music]
this video is made possible by Pacific
Arc and Faulkner Brown's architects
it's another magnificent morning in
beautiful Vancouver
I fill my lungs with the air of the city
the textures the sound the smell they
all inspire me
[Music]
I breathe in the aura of the mountains
the ocean as I start my day full of
inspiration and creativity
these days most of my time is spent on
construction for a library renovation
here in BC
our team worked really hard with the
library and the city to come up with a
design that we're all super excited
about and I just can't wait for the
thing that we designed finally get built
uh 54 emails
[Music]
oh shoot can't corn to the slap due to
existing electrical conduits Nate
answers ASAP
[Music]
this whole process is called CA
Construction contract Administration
this is the phase after the design phase
after you've created all the
construction drawings and written all
your specs after you've selected your
contractor and now you're getting ready
to build your design typically the
architect is responsible for
administering the contract between the
client and the contractor you have to
make sure that the proper products are
ordered and if there's any questions
they get answered quickly and basically
making sure that the design is being
built to your design intent we do
everything from reviewing shop drawings
or answering questions from the
contractors we do site reviews we
certify payments and if the contractor
claims for any extras we administer that
to make sure that it's fair and
warranted for this project is a
renovation of an existing building so a
lot of things did come up that we didn't
really expect for example we're
demolishing these existing washrooms to
turn them into Universal gender neutral
washrooms but when they scan the slab to
start coring for the toilets they found
electrical conduits in the slab that
weren't on the asbo drawings now a
really big part of an architect's job is
coordinating between all the different
parties involved in construction and
with your consultant so first I'll go to
our electrical consultant and I'll ask
him is it okay if we core into this and
in this case he was like yeah it's
potentially an important conduit but it
will be impossible to know what it leads
to unless we actually trace the conduit
in the slab back to the source and of
course in a perfect world with an
infinite amount of time and money we
would probably do that it but the
library they need to open at a certain
time so that they can serve the public
so then you have a chat with a
contractor is this feasible
realistically how long do you think this
is going to take and So after talking to
them you might be like okay maybe a
better solution is just to go with long
toilets instead of floor mounted but if
we do that we're gonna need a much
bigger Plumbing wall here and now it's
an architectural issue these stalls are
getting really really tight so you could
move this wall out a little bit which is
going to eat into the holes area and so
you go and ask the library what do you
think about this and in this case the
answer was no because they'd be losing
an entire bookshelf and so now you go to
your last resort which is to move this
wall six inches down
so you're not going to get your five
foot turning radius here but you know by
code that's actually okay because this
over here is the only accessible stall
so anyways your job as an architect is
to talk to all of the parties involved
with the building code and accessibility
in mind and try to come up with the best
possible solution after everything's
been considered when you're in
construction everything is gonna seem
super super
urgent but a part of being an architect
and doing CA is learning to separate the
really urgent ones from the ones that
can kind of wait
all right let's talk about something a
little bit more exciting materials these
are the options for the concrete finish
this is going to go in throughout the
building and so what we're doing is
we're specifying two different aggregate
sizes that are going to go side by side
and there's going to be a aluminum
reveal in between them so they're going
to have the exact same color but they're
gonna have different aggregate sizes the
other thing to note here is we have
existing concrete columns in the
building
and so we have to make sure that this
concrete overlayment that we're putting
in here matches or at least works with
the existing concrete columns which are
slightly on the brown side so I'm kind
of leaning away from these cooler tones
right now
option one has a 1.2 to two millimeter
Aggregate and the spacing between the
Aggregates are tighter I think this is
probably the best for hiding
imperfections or scratches
there's going to be a lot about four
millimeter options
much better than the other aggregate
size
I decided to make a quick visit site
because
I couldn't decide
I need to go see it in the existing
space against the existing columns
ah I love coming here
the library is the heart of this
community a true Urban Courtyard
thank you
[Music]
again
[Music]
this is the project that I've been
working on for the past year and a half
and uh it's a renovation we are taking
some of the existing space that's used
for books and sorting and after doing a
pretty thorough analysis we realize that
they don't really use the library for
that stuff anymore and so we're turning
a lot of those spaces into public space
um we're creating a digital media lab
we're renovating The Atrium so that it
becomes a communal Gathering space it's
been really really really awesome
working with the Librarians like they're
super passionate they're very very
knowledgeable and they are able to
gather information and compile them in a
very organized manner so they're kind of
like the best possible client
so yeah it's been really fun and it's
really cool to finally see this thing
come to life
[Music]
so the decision was actually pretty
obvious when I put it side to side with
the existing column sometimes you just
have to make the trip to site to make
these kind of big decisions can you
guess which one we picked
at the end of the day I like to draw but
ever since my project has gone into
construction I rarely have time to
express my creativity I've been using
this drafting board by Pacific Arc the
smooth melamine surface the parallel bar
with the aluminum trim the seamless
movement all combined to create this
fine drawing experience with these
folding legs I can store them away and
it's even got a handle that makes it
super portable I actually really love
their products and I pretty much use
them on a daily basis whether I'm at
work or sketching on my free time so
I've partnered with Pacific Arc to give
you guys 15 off their entire line of
product starting from now till December
3rd whether you're in school or you're
looking for a Christmas gift you can
follow the link in the description and
use code one five damnilee to get your
discount
my best drawing companion to help me get
my ideas down or to help me wind down at
the end of the day
[Music]